You find a sweater with
a nice wide neck band.
And at first you might think I'll just use
my favorite sweater pattern
and knit a wider band.
But wait, let's think about this a bit.
Let's say your preferred neck
opening looks like this.
This one is fairly high, maybe eight
inches wide and two to three inches deep.
And this is how you'd like your
sweater to rest against your neck.
As knitters we will probably want to add some
sort of band to finish this neckline.
But to add the band and maintain our
desired neck opening, we need
to modify the sweater neck opening.
We'll make the neck opening larger
and the neck depth deeper
to accommodate that band.
Let's take this one step further.
For a designer look.
Maybe we'll want our band
four or five inches deep.
We'll need to cut out the garment
pieces to accommodate that band.
By altering the garment pieces,
we can knit the band to any depth we want
and still maintain the original
desired finished neck opening.
For Knit it Now patterns,
alter the neck depth and the neck width
to accommodate your planned band.